all right let's get into audience
questions for the week
one that i've been getting from people
all over the world
with anecdotes and also from americans
asking
what is going on elsewhere in the world
is
what is the reaction around the world to
donald trump's
refusal to accept that he simply lost
his continued pro promotion of
these completely baseless factless
conspiracy theories about voter fraud
and massive
dumps as he talked about over the
weekend
and that he really won georgia and he
really won pennsylvania and so on
how does the world see it and the answer
is that
much of the world is laughing but a lot
of the world is also
really concerned by by what they are
seeing and of course the question
spot on that it's been a month
there's been no real concession from
trump where he says
i got i got beat i was defeated uh joe
biden got more votes in more states
donald trump has sort of danced around
it he's authorized the transition to
start and we'll talk about that
transition a little bit later in this
segment
he has sort of almost had some verbal
slip ups where he says
you know we won't do a shutdown i don't
know if the next
uh i mean i can't speak for anybody else
but we won't do a shutdown right that
we've seen that stuff and we've even
seen reports of trump privately
understanding that he doesn't have a
path to victory
but there's been no real concession from
donald trump
a lot of the world is laughing and tends
to see trump more as just
an idiot uh and that includes like
anecdotally the people i hear from
who watch the show who are in ireland
just like as one example
they are more on the we can't believe
this idiotic [ __ ]
and the things that he is doing
anecdotally again
our viewers from germany they don't
seem to be finding the humor in it as
much as some others
and they seem genuinely worried about
the state of our democracy now maybe
that's something about
germany's past that informs how the
germans i'm hearing from
are reacting differently to the irish
folks that i'm hearing from
but when the world sees that world
leaders are calling biden
they're talking about getting things
done with joe biden they're getting
started on a variety of projects and
issues
it's biden that world leaders are now
dealing with when it comes to
coronavirus as an example joe biden's
task force
already uh seemingly more ready and
willing to get things done than the one
that donald trump has had in place for
more than half a year at this point in
time and so
while there is some laughter and some
pointing and some look at that idiot in
the united states
there is also the doubt that the world
is
increasingly experiencing about like
what is the standing of the united
states in terms of a democracy
what is going on with the strength of
american checks and balances that this
continues to go on and then
if you're paying attention to the legal
maneuvers that the trump
legal team is trying it's the stuff of
shame
not putting in the legal briefs the
things they say publicly
like there was actual fraud they don't
put that in the legal briefs because
they know they don't have the evidence
for it and
earlier this week we had this clip of
news anchors from brazil
unable to contain their laughter at
donald trump's bizarre press conference
on thanksgiving day
there's also a lot of straight-up
pointing and laughing there's no there's
certainly no shortage of it
we are increasingly seen as an unstable
country
one that cannot be trusted in deals the
iran deal being the perfect example
any foreign deal made with one president
could be thrown out
by the next president as donald trump
did with the iran deal
even though iran didn't actually violate
any aspects of that deal
so this is you know the big picture
is whether you're laughing or crying or
scared or whatever your view is of
what's going on
embarrassed for the united states the
big picture is
how can such a rich country considered
to be
the leader on so many issues until only
a short time ago
how can we be having these problems how
can we be having
uh um the the a president
who can't even tell the truth for a
minute when the topic of whether he lost
comes up how do we have so many people
without health care and people on food
stamps and people lacking basic
education and crumbling infrastructure
laughable airports
considered to other rich countries right
like the problems are of course bigger
than donald trump
how do we have this religious not
anti-science
thing running rampant even not just
people
but people in positions of power in the
united states
some of this stuff joe biden can start
to write
some of it takes much longer and it's
much more than just a president can do
and it goes well beyond the
the oval office and so we've really got
our work cut out for us
um and and the world is noticing now a
lot of trumpets don't care
a lot of trumpists say why [ __ ]
europeans don't like what we're doing it
must mean we're doing the right thing i
mean that's the approach
that a lot of these trumpists have and
that's part of what we need to fix here
if you ever feel like you just don't
have enough time to read all the books
you want to read
you have to check out one of my favorite
apps called blinkist blinkist takes
thousands of popular nonfiction books
and distills each one down into an
e-book
or audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book
just imagine how you'll be able to
expand your horizons and knowledge
by being able to soak up all of the
important insights from
10 different books in an afternoon
obviously it's perfect for exposing
yourself to a new book
you otherwise wouldn't have time for or
you can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video